hello there i'm alana and today we are
doing another
sort of reaction video it's not really a
reaction video
it's more just that i didn't have time
to watch this during the week because
i have a very demanding schedule and a
full-time job
um so we are watching the pokemon
presents
from the 26th of february i'm catching
up on it now i really wanted to watch
this one as
pretty much a lifelong pokemon fan but
uh you know
just sometimes i just decide to record
it at the same time it's essentially
what's happening
now i've not really had anything from
this spoiled except for the
hint of there maybe being an open world
pokemon game
which i have wanted for so long
like if anyone has asked me the question
of what is your ideal pokemon game
sorry your ideal video game in general i
mean for the last like decade
plus my answer has been like a true open
world pokemon rpg
where i could choose to be part of team
rocket or choose to be
a trainer or choose to run a poker
center or i want a bethesda-esque
pokemon game i don't imagine that's what
they're going to give me but i have
heard whispers of this thing
that naturally i'm very curious about so
um yeah without
further delay let's watch it shall we
it's still 14 on trending on youtube
i'm not much older than pokemon it has
really been with me my entire life
that's crazy it just turned 25 and i
just turned 27.
1996. and both of those
red green tables
so good they were like so big my whole
childhood how dare you i still don't
have that charizard somebody stole it
from me in primary school
dude oh all of this oh
pokemon stadium
i never had that
[Music]
i never played that either
[Music]
that i still have of all these um shiny
like holographic crystals pokemon like
little things they came
i don't even know what they came in like
in chip packets or something pokemon as
a kid was so much fun to grow up with
rule very glad i grew up in the area
that i did
in pot because of all of this
database
2002. this mini game is so much fun
cable cable cable
[Music]
wireless adapter and the road
i've had goosebumps like this whole time
they're really kicking me right in the
feels out here
[Music]
2006 diamond pearl
[Music]
not golden soul silva transfer i did
have one of those
[Music]
this is so good
incredibly well-made
[Music]
we should feel like that haven't been
around for that long that's a while ago
i don't know why in my head it seems
more recent
[Music]
oh
also the first few months of pokemon go
[Music]
were amazing
[Music]
huh
[Music]
i feel like i missed that this is very
good advertising for someone who already
really likes pokemon
not that they really need it the highest
grossing franchise ever
[Applause]
[Music]
pokemon's a big franchise
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
buddy
[Music]
this is making me emotional and i don't
know why
why am i tearing up at
very well crafted marketing i'm like oh
my god my whole life
oh my we haven't god
gotten anything new yet and i'm just ham
[Music]
[Applause]
it really has been there the whole time
wild and there's more this isn't the
whole video like i could have just done
that
hello everyone i'm ishihara from the
pokemon company
february 27th is the day pokemon red
and pokemon green were released in japan
marking the beginning of the pokemon
series
so wild an astounding 25 years have
passed since the pokemon series was born
we've shared so much with you over the
past 25 years
through our games but also through so
many other mediums
thanks to the support you've all shown
us
thank you each and every one of you
today thank you mister we'll introduce
our appreciate
hello there my name is utsunomiya from
the pokemon company
first i'd like to give you the first
update on the new pokemon snap game
and dress together a video that will
show you some of the
[Music]
of gameplay pokemon snap this is the
lentil region
you'll ride the neo one through the
jungle
across the desert and even under the sea
to research pokemon in their natural
habitats
and of course you won't be alone
professor mir who's doing research in
the lentil region
and research team members rita and phil
are there to support you no this means
we don't have professor oak like
just brutally nagging us the whole time
research started telling me how shitty
my photos are
damn you okay come on you can discover
behaviors and expressions
that are rarely seen look i have no
doubt that this game will be super fun
that's cool and there's vaporeon
let's try throwing it up still got you
throwing your apples
important gameplay mechanics
oh it's tyranitar
what a wild way to eat who do you
pokemon really like apples too
here's a park at night let's try playing
a melody
oh that's music that sure made hoot
happy
that's cool i was hoping that would be
you'll also have more illumina orbs
something the professor mechanics if you
use one of these
you can make any pokemon glow huh
[Music]
but why whoa those flames different
animations maybe
it's pretty photo variety make good use
of your tools
to take shots that really stand out very
cool
show the photos you took to the
professor oh
four stars we captured a rare moment
there
catch a variety of different behaviors
on camera
to fill up your pokemon photo decks i
hope they change their writing system a
little bit
you'll be able to edit oh needs you've
taken cool
that's cool this is gonna be so good on
the internet use features like stickers
and
the way this is gonna blow up on twitter
it's gonna be really fun
and i'm sure you'll want to show off
your best photos right
we know that feeling well when you want
to do that
it's time to go online you can share
your favorite photos
and check out photos from around the
world and if your photo becomes popular
it might even be featured and get more
attention
seeing something like that may inspire
you to go back and take
even more photos we're getting closer to
the start of your adventure
unexplored islands it does look pretty
pokemon await in the lentil region
so make sure you're prepared i wonder if
if that like
home-based area is an area you can
actually walk around in or is the whole
thing still just on rails
that looks much better so far than the
new level in the original
region i'm super on board i'm sure it's
gonna be really fun and like really
pleasant
it's not that far away i didn't know
that that's awesome i can't wait to
stream that game it's gonna be so much
fun
i liked it thank you for asking forward
to the game's release on april 30th
hell yeah next i'd like to tell you
about several events we're holding to
celebrate pokemon day in the pokemon
sword and pokemon shield games
special max raid battles featuring
gigantomax pikachu
that's a big pikachu
we're holding a promotion in which you
can receive 2 500 golden acorns for
logging in
i probably missed all this i think i
have
moltres and even youtube are appearing
in legendary raid battles as part of a
kanto themed celebration event
i didn't know that and i'm upset i'm on
masters ex
i think i have everyone in leon and his
partner pokemon charizard
i don't know if i have a mewtwo i feel
like i should check that
we hope there's still times next
i'd like to present the latest news
about the pokemon video game series
have a look at this video i will thank
you
[Music]
the production value of just nintendo
directs in general
um i guess this technically isn't
classified as a direct
it's a pokemon presents but um
they just make them so well
like there's so much more effort put in
i feel like it's not just like a bunch
of gameplay trailers
of course they are there but um
there's often like some nice real world
stuff in there too that isn't necessary
it's just like
artsy
[Music]
oh there's hair physics look at you go
[Music]
damn
nice i never played diamond so
actually i did i just didn't finish it
happy about it cool that looks dope to
me
never know like what the pokemon
community's takeaway of anything is
because i feel like the
the larger pokemon community seems to be
very angry about everything all the time
whereas i'm generally like
yes i will i will shut up and consume
[Laughter]
this is like maybe the open world one
that i'm very curious about
this is a tale from a long long time ago
when the sinnoh region was still only a
vast
wilderness i'm already very into
a certain village bustled with the
comings and goings of people
while in the mountains and seas pokemon
roamed as they pleased
okay
dude dude
[Music]
oh man
[Music]
i want this so bad
oh my gosh
[Music]
is that it i would really like to see
more
oh boy
[Music]
[Applause]
so
this is all good pokemon so the
franchise is called
oh it's next year um the the
the new series is called legends two new
additions to the pokemon video game
series
both taking place in the sinnoh region
first i'd like to present the pokemon
brilliant diamond
and pokemon shining pearl games these
are faithful critics of the pokemon
diamond version and pokemon pearl
version games
which were released for the nintendo ds
system in japan
15 years ago
the pokemon brilliant diamond and
pokemon shining pearl games
remakes of the pokemon diamond version
and pokemon they're doing such a good
job with these remakes which were
released for the nintendo ds system
are coming to nintendo's switch again i
feel like that's controversial
across a lot of the pokemon pokemon home
the project is being directed by yuichi
ueda of ilka
as well as game freak's junichi masuda
who is the director for the original
pokemon diamond version
and pokemon pro version games your
adventure will take place
in the sinnoh region rich in nature and
with towering mount coronet at its heart
it is a land of many myths passed down
through the ages
the sense of scale of the original
game's towns and roots
has been carefully preserved and you'll
be able to travel through familiar
locations once again
you'll set out on your journey after
choosing either turtwig
chimchar or piplup as your first partner
pokemon
in these games you can enjoy a grand
adventure together
with all the pokemon from pokemon
diamond version
and pokemon pearl version newcomers and
previous visitors to the sinnoh region
alike
he went forward to experiencing the
original pokemon diamond and pokemon
pearl stories
freshly recreated for nintendo switch
it is nice to to know that um you think
pokemon can kind of live forever and
pokemon shining pearl
totally new audiences who otherwise
would never have played these games
that that's so accessible now by looking
more familiar to you adventure in the
cinema
modern video games and on modern
platforms
next allow me to introduce you to the
pokemon launcher nintendo really does
have me rebuying a lot of [ __ ]
legends arceus represents a new approach
for the pokemon video game series
development is in full swing at game
freak with the aim to deliver a gaming
experience that breaks new ground for
the pokemon series
my posture is
i'm hyped okay somebody gets in your
shoulders when you get excited
the events of this game unfold in the
sinnoh of
old and this time too mount coronette
towers over the center of the region
pokemon live freely in the wild here but
the harsh environments may be different
from the sinnoh region you remember
[Music]
in this era people have journeyed to
sinnoh from all over
and founded a prosperous village in the
hope of learning
more about this land it's giving me a
breath of the wild vibes but i'm sure
it's not come on
cyndaquil and it seems they were brought
to sinnoh by a certain professor
who encountered them while traveling
around various regions
you'll set off on your adventure after
receiving a first partner pokemon of
your own
from this professor
[Music]
with the village as your base you'll
venture out to the different corners of
the kitchen
on your quest to create synthetic very
first polka dots home base
function says if anything wild pokemon
can be caught with pokeballs
you can also engage in pokemon battles
alongside your pokemon allies
sharpen your skills for both catching
and battling pokemon and strive to
complete your looks cool
now for the musical confirmation
embraces the game's title and story
arceus
how is this pokemon connected to your
journey
[Music]
the answer to this question and more
awaits you in this exciting new action
rpg adventure
for the nintendo switch system listen
i want more information about this open
world and what you could do in it
but i am very on board and i'm willing
to wait for more information i
understand come on legends
we'll launch simultaneously on the world
early next year
cool we hope you're all excited to set
out on these adventures across
thank you that's very distinctly
different from the other
with the wonderfully nostalgic pokemon
brilliant diamond and pokemon shining
pearl
as well as the pokemon video game series
new journey
pokemon legends arceus
as pokemon celebrates 25 years we will
continue to challenge ourselves
and deliver new ways for everyone to
enjoy pokemon even more
thank you very much for watching i
thought that was a really good
presentation overall
um they're super concise with them
a lot of good info definitely hit me in
the nostalgia
i had a good time uh yeah
i know i i like i mentioned a couple of
times i did see that
there was like people talking about the
pokemon community being mad but i didn't
actually see any of that anger so i have
no input on any of that but very excited
about this legends
thing and how many of them we might get
because that is
something i've always wanted but i would
hope that you can actually role play in
it
um by which i mean have it be an rpg
like
like uh like a skyrim type uh justin
that i wanna like have cool side quests
where i can
join a guild or something you know just
a lot of different options
would be really cool but we ultimately
have no idea pokemon snap
very into it was hoping there'd be new
mechanics nice to see those on display
um
i still don't think it looks great
graphically which people were pretty
upset with me for last time
but i just think a lot of uh it looks
it looks colorful um but for a game that
is like on rails and about photography
i feel like the style that there just
could be more detail in those
environments still
um but i seem to be an outlier on my
take on that regardless
definitely gonna play it glad it's
coming in april
apparently and uh yeah now i'm caught up
i like pokemon deck it continues to
remain the same
when that is concerned um but otherwise
that is it for me today everyone
i'll see you guys next time